hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that you just finished
from round three of this year's video
World Cup it is Maxima shellegra versus
Java cristindarova and both of them are
really extraordinary players of course
Maxime needs no introduction he's been
in the affiliate World Cup many many
times two times in 2013 and 2017 he got
into the all the way to the semi-finals
and in 2019 he even got third place in
defeated World Cup and now he would very
much enjoy uh taking it all the way and
qualify for the candidates tournament
where on the other hand we have Joker
cindero who is uh well almost 100 rating
points lower rated but as all the other
Grandmasters from Uzbekistan he is he's
just the deadly in 2021 also in the fidi
World Cup he knocked out alireza firuja
in round two if you guys remember after
drawing the classical games and then
going into tie break so he is uh he he
knocked out alireza two years ago he can
definitely play against anyone and here
it's a very short game and uh well
something terrible happens for one of
the Players let's check it out and you
guys will have a great pause the video
moment not too great pause the video
moment so let's dive straight into it
Maxine with the white pieces opens with
E4 and we have Pawn to E5 all right so
going for the symmetrical stuff Knight
to F3 Knight the C6 and Maxime goes for
the Royal Lopez Bishop to B5 with a six
morphe's defense that should pay for
Knight to F6 and now castles and Bishop
to C5 so the standard stuff the Neo
archangels variation see through all the
molars defense it's been called by many
names C3 we have B5 attacking the bishop
Bishop to C2 and now Pawn to D5 again
been played many times D for the
absolute stop move here but here we have
Pawn to A4 by Maxine going for an
extremely sharp line D cap D captures an
E4 a captures on B5 and now e captures
an F3 a very early peace Sacrifice by
Maxine uh and now he just plays Queen
captures on F3 where he wants to capture
the Knight either by the pawn or by the
queen or if the Knight moves You're
Gonna Lose the rook and A8 so what can
you play here of course Ponte E4 but it
doesn't really do all that much Bishop
captures an E4 and now Knight the E5
offers The Rook but the queen here is
attacked and just Queen back to E2 now
if some of you are wondering uh can you
actually give up the queen here not
really you could play something like
Bishop capture Sun A8 Knight captures
here and Bishop captures on F3 but after
a move like Queen to D3 you have I mean
okay you don't have a material
compensation regardless of how you play
it but uh here your your position is
just terrible plus you're done material
I know some of you were probably
thinking about that so here after this
Knight to E5 we have Queen back to E2
and now castles and here uh what's
what's the move that you play do you
play Pawn to D4 and go after the the
fork here or do you play Bishop captures
on A8 while Bishop to captures uh
captures an A8 is a very nice move it's
a really really complicated one because
after Bishop captures an A8 you get this
nasty Knight the D3 move now again
completely paralyzing the development of
white species and now after let's say
Pawn to B4 you want to chase away the
bishop Rook E8 attacks the queen and
there is no good Square for the White
Queen the best move is just Queen
captures and E8 if you play some like
Queen F3 then Bishop to G4 comes if
Queen G3 then Bishop to D6 comes and now
now you're just the dead lost if Queen
to H4 You're Gonna Play Bishop D2 now
with the thread of Bishop captures on F1
also Queen captures an A8 is a threat uh
just a complete mess so while it can be
played uh you can't really play it just
like this you have to play it the engine
perfect so instead after castles you
have Pawn to D4 uh going after the
Knight and Bishop and okay The Rook is
still hanging uh Bishop to G for now
attacking the White Queen and now again
can we play F3 here well if you play F3
uh then uh Java kill just gives back the
piece Bishop captures on the 4C captures
Queen captures on D4 uh with the check
of course and after Queen to E3 you just
trade everything down captures captures
You're Gonna Play Knight captures and E4
uh Pawn captures somewhere or you can
even play B captures on A6 if you want
to postpone the capture a sort of
creating a pass Pawn but regardless of
how you play it uh black will always be
a little bit better for example Rook
captures Rook captures and now uh you're
up a pawn and the black has a slightly
better Pawn structure so black would be
better here so probably in that position
you should just capture on A6 and
postpone the capture so F3 is not the
best of moves with uh instead after
Bishop to G4 we have Queen to C2 now you
you do have some pressure on that H7
Pawn so Knight captures an E4 Queen
captures an E4 and now attacking this
puts pressure on the bishop so Bishop
back to D7 and now B captures an A6 uh
Maxime creates a past a pawn bishop to
B5 attacks the pawn and the rookani one
and now Queen captures an E5
uh sacrifices The Exchange Bishop
captures on F1 King characters and now
Bishop to A7 so even against the real
Lopez uh even in the Rue Lopez Maxim
finds a way to sacrifice The Exchange
it's a it's a rarely very rare that you
will uh see Maxim playing a game without
sacrificing The Exchange somewhere uh so
Knight to D2 uh you have to uh you have
to start developing your pieces and now
Pawn to C5 putting pressure on the
center and while you can create a pass
Pawn immediately with D5 Maxim says all
right let's first get our pieces uh on
optimal optimal squares it's not like
black can do anything to prevent this
and even with captures captures which
was played in the game still you will be
able to advance your past Pawn so Rook
to E8 attacks uh Maxim's queen queen to
F5 and now Bishop captures on D4 winning
back uh one of the pawns and offering
the bishop for Knight but maxim of
course goes for checkmate he plays
Knight to G5 now threatens Queen
captures an H7 and queen captures on F7
Ponte H6 it would be a terrible mistake
to play upon to H6 because then it's
just a queen captures on F7 uh no sorry
G6 would be a terrible mistake because
then this would just be Checkmate but H6
actually can be played uh because now
while you can capture on F7 uh after
King th8 you don't really have uh all
that many squares yes you you can
threaten even Checkmate because the
Knight is hanging so you just have to go
back and then the bishop moves and the
game continues where black is always
slightly better but maybe it's even the
best course of action after this H6 move
however in the game Queen the H7 check
was played we have King to f8 and now
you just go back the problem is okay it
looks like maybe you could do something
with this unlike Bishop to D2 with
Bishop to B4 uh well well it is very
nice if you play this black will just
stop it with Queen to B6 and you don't
really have a move you can't even play
Rook to A4 to prepare this because if
let's say Rook a four then Queen B5
check picks up the Rook on A4 so there's
really no way to do it instead after
King to a fade Knight back to F3 okay
this attacks the bishop and now Queen to
B6 defending the bishop and here uh Maxi
makes his first real mistake of the game
uh and he plays Knight captures on D4
here the way you to play this is just to
continue development Bishop to D2 yes
you have to give up the pawn but what
are you gonna do if Rook B1 or queen
captures on A6 you have to give up
another pawn and after King G1 now you
have to play something like F5 in order
to help out with the defense of the
black king you can even give up this
Pawn it's not really a problem just
Queen back to F6 and now the game
continues but black is always up the
exchange however you put it you don't
need the
uh you know uh more than that but
instead after Queen to B6 Knight
captures on D4 was played by Maxim and
now feel free to pause the video and try
to find the move that Maxi missed and
the move that will cost him the uh well
uh the the chance to to win or or even
maybe just qualify for the candidates in
defeated World Cup uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a rook
captures on A6 that is the move that has
to be played here and I will show you
why but you know just in case I I forgot
I forget to mention it congratulations
to everyone who founded you're a true uh
supporter of incredible moves because if
Queen captures on D4 then you just
developed Bishop E3 and if Rook captures
an A6 now yes you cannot capture the
queen because the root captures on A1
will result in Checkmate you can just
move the rook and then the game
continues black didn't really do all
that much however after Rook captures an
A6 not a lot can be done here because if
you if you trade Rooks then Queen
captures on A6 comes with check you
cannot touch the E file so you have to
go back and not just Rook D1 is
Checkmate so it's that simple however
after Rook captures an A6 Maxim
instantly played Pawn to G3 sort of uh
announcing that maybe maybe it's Joker
that blundered with Rook characters on
A6 because now he's will to give up the
rook and the bishop to play Knight to F5
and to Checkmate the black king so what
is happening here uh you tell me feel
free to pause the video for the second
time and win the game for cinder of
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations and again looking
past the obvious and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to B7 that is the move that wins
the game and there is no defense here
Queen to H1 is coming and The Rook cuts
of the king from the e file and that's
pretty much it the game did continue for
uh for a few more moves and we will show
it but just to show you what the Maxim's
idea was it was after Rook captures an
A1 for those of you who were thinking
that Knight to F5 now threatens
Checkmate and uh now of course if you
capture the bishop here then you you
just lose the game if King to G2 you can
give one more check King H3 and now okay
F6 the queen does sort of defend but
then just a nice check the King has them
the King has to move you're gonna
deliver another checking E6 and now you
blunder the queen so that's one thing
and after Knight to F5 if you don't do
that the the the only way for black to
draw is to not go for this is to
actually play Rook to E1 with check but
white will ignore you King to G2 because
then Rook comes with check and
then black will be better so here King
T8 this is how you avoid Checkmate and
after a queen to G8 checking to D7 Queen
captures an F7 checking to see it and
now Queen the f8 with check Queen to d8
and now you're gonna have some sort of a
Perpetual with Queen to f8 the C5 check
or it doesn't really matter how you do
it uh it's a very very dangerous
position to be in you will have to
settle for a Perpetual here however
after G3 Queen to B7 was played and now
there is no Escape now Maxim has to play
something Queen to each checking the E7
and now probably best would be to trade
the queen for Rook but this is just you
know okay you're gonna play for for a
while but you're gonna lose the game so
he didn't play that I'm just gonna show
it to you Rook captures on A6 let's say
queen captures and you have a bishop and
Knight for a queen okay you do have the
past B Pawn and you can push it to B4 uh
so you know it's not it's not that
terrible but of course objectively black
is much much better here so Queen
captures and G7 was played instead but
now we have Rook captures on A1 and the
bishop is off next we have Knight to F5
with the check King the E6 Knights the
D4 with check King to D5 and now Knight
to F3 and just Rook captures on C1 with
check with King to G2 and now Rook the
C4 uh Queen captures on H6 and now Rook
to E6 and he was in this position on
move 34 that Maxima Shiela grab resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here now there's simply too much
material uh Java is up in exchange and a
full Rook so it would be pointless to
start playing this of course so the
queen controls this diagonal so even the
Knight can't really move and it's very
very simple to actually finish this
you're just gonna let's say hide the
king behind the black queen
uh the the queen already controls this
diagonal so this is perfect and you're
probably going to put the Rooks on F5
and F6 uh hone in on that Knight on F3
and just start capturing there is
absolutely nothing uh Maxim can do about
this uh so yeah big congratulations that
the syndrome it seems that the maxim
will not be going
um uh to the finals or the candidates
through defeated World Cup but for
General care that option still exists uh
so yeah and that's the game really hope
you guys enjoyed it brilliant stuff by
Jacob and uh like uh uh Peter leko uh
mentioned in in the commentary during
this game uh after night characters and
D4 was played and uh well uh Queen
characters and D4 did not come as an
automatic response once you see this and
once you feel this you know you just
captured and you you know that your
opponent has to capture you know in your
head you already decided that that is
the only move that can be played and
your opponent just starts thinking that
is the the scariest moment uh there can
possibly be you know that you've
blundered something and you know you're
you're probably done for uh but yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank lurcher Paul
Harris Samuel Kane Aaron is the best
wife and no Laura is the best wife for
her contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
defeated World Cup until it finishes uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day